>>
SANDHOLM: My name is Anders, Anders Sandholm,
I'm a member of the Chrome team and so is
Pavel Feldman who will join me in a bit in
talking about Chrome Development Tools. We're
both very excited to be here and to be able
to talk about some of the work we've been
doing over the past year. And in fact, we
came here all the way from Europe to be with
you today to talk about this. We'll go through
some of the new exciting features in the Chrome
Development Tools. Just--before we get started,
I wanted to get a feel for, you know, to what
extent we're barking up the wrong tree. So
amongst you when you, you know, when you're
developing web apps just let me see, like,
a show of hands, you know, how many of you
are using Firebug on a regular basis for doing
that? Okay. So that's a fair share. How many
of you know Web Inspector and the Chrome Developer
Tools?
>> Yeah
>> SANDHOLM: Yeah. How many of you use it
on a regular basis when debugging web apps?
>> Yeah
>> SANDHOLM: Okay. So it's some. Okay. So
if nothing else, I hope that at least, you
know, after this session, you have seen some
exciting features in Chrome Developer Tools
and maybe want to try it out and give it a
spin. One more thing before we get started,
as you can see at the bottom of the screen,
there's a link. You might want to note that
down. There'll be live notes and you can ask
questions for this session. It's a wave that's
specific to this session. Also at the end,
obviously, we will have some time for questions.
And I will--we'll take questions here from
the audience as well. Right, so let me talk
a little bit about what we're going to cover
in the session. Essentially, this is going
to be about, you know, tools that you can
use for debugging and optimizing your web
apps. The structures are as follows--I'll
talk a bit about what Chrome Developer Tools
is and give you a bit of a brief background
of the history of the project what we've been
doing over the past year or so, and then I'll
pass on the floor to Pavel, who'll talk in
more detail about the tools itself. A quick
walkthrough of the panels or the overall features
available in the tool, and then after that,
a few developer stories if you want or issues
that--when you think you find familiar if
you've been developing web servers. And we'll
show how the Developer Tools in Chrome can
help you or support you in those tasks. If
time permits, we can cover a little bit also
the internal design of Dev Tools. And then
obviously at the end, we'll have a time for
questions. So again, as you've guessed maybe
from the title or from the questions I asked
before. If you think about what Chrome Developer
Tools is or what this session is going to
be about, it is--you can think of it essentially--since
so many know and use Firebug, you can think
of it essentially as, you know, Chrome Dev
Tools being to Chrome where Firebug is to
Firefox? It's not a part of Firebug, but rather
it's something based on the Web Inspector
in WebKit. It is not something you have to
download if you're using Chrome as part of
the standard Chrome distributions. So it's
right there and you can use it with the browser.
And one way to think about it if you're familiar
with the Inspector is the--one way to think
about if you're familiar with the Inspector
is essentially is the Web Inspector running
with the JavaScript engine specific to Chrome,
namely V8 underneath, plus supporting Chromes
multi-process architecture. This allows us
to develop new features so that they'll be
available in all WebKit browsers or in some
cases where we're utilizing features that
are specific to V8. We've been able to launch
features that are available as part of the
Inspector but, for a start, may only be available
in Chrome. Right, so let me continue with
a brief background of the history of the Dev
Tools in Chrome. So essentially, you know,
Chrome launch a little over--or about a year
and half ago. And at the very beginning, there
was only a rudimentary support for developers.
So, it's a--basically a command line debugger
and the ability to do some inspection of the
DOM. And what I wanted to show with this page
is essentially two things. What you see in
each line is a panel. So you can think that
there's a group of features available in the
tool. And as you can see with newer Chrome
releases, we keep adding more stuff and the
panels are mentioned again because we actually
keep improving on the stuff that's already
in there as well. The major thing happened
about a year ago, if you look at the first
release which is the first Chrome version,
there was rudimentary support. Chrome 2 is
not even mentioned because somewhere between
Chrome 2 and 3 is when Pavel and his team
got started actively working on this out of
our St. Petersburg office. And that meant
that with Chrome 3 and onwards, we've been
able to keep adding new features so that we
are what we are today and, in fact, some of
the later features that were added, Pavel's
going to talk about in more detail and how
they'll be useful in your data work hopefully,
so with that, over to you Pavel to talk more
about the actual tool.
>> FELDMAN: Okay, thank you Anders. My name
is Pavel Feldman and I'm a software engineer
working on Chrome Developer Tools and WebKit
Web Inspector. Today, I'll be doing a quick
overview of the Chrome Developer Tools functionality
for you and continue it with the--a number
of developer stories that I'm sure you'll
find interesting. During these stories, I'll
show you some previews of new features that
we have recently added into the Chrome Developer
Tools. But before we go there, I want to mention
that since Chrome Developer Tools is heavily
base on WebKit Web Inspector, it's essentially
a single source. All--everything I'm going
to talk about is available in any WebKit-based
browser that has Developer Tools enabled.
So--however, the developer stories I'm going
to talk about are full of the functionality
that is base on the V8 engine capabilities
that are not necessarily a V8 in other JavaScript
engines. So that functionality will only be
available in Chrome, at least for now. I won't
have too much slides for you today, so it'll
be all live demos pretty much. So the Developer
Tools overview is just a walkthrough to the
existing panels and the perspectives of Developer
Tools. And the stories are the real world
of--real stories about debugging of your JavaScript
applications, memory profiling them, performance
profiling them. With that, let me actually
switch to running Chrome instance. And I'm
running a Chrome full screen here. Let me
start with bringing the Developer Tools on
the screen. So I'm using shortcut command
"Option+I" on Mac or "Ctrl+Shift+I" on Windows
and Linux. And here it is. The Developer Tools
Window is opened in the docked note. Let me
undock it. So I'm using a status bar button
to undock it. Here it is. Now we start with
the Elements panel. That's the first in the
row and the Elements panel is where you spend
your time designing your app visually, tweaking
its lay-out, its style, working with the CSS,
with the DOM notes. You can see that the big
part of the screen is a DOM tree. And this
DOM tree is, in fact, live. So whenever a
document object model over your webpage is
changing, these changes are reflected in the
screen. Now we can not only traverse through
the element here, you could mutate your DOM.
I can double click to edit attributes, I can
tap through them, I can tap to create a new
element--a new attribute place holder. I can
even rename the tag name. I can also use context
menu to edit these HTML. And editing as HTML
is as flexible as it could be, so you can
add tags there, you could paste or create
HTML snippets there. Do whatever you want.
Now for each of these notes we have a number
of properties inspected to the right. What
are these? These are the computer style. And
the computer style is a number of styles as
the rendering engine perceives it. So that's
how it is going to render your element. Now
that one is read-only. Then there is this
styles pane. And the styles pane is a number
of styles that are applied to your element
as they are defined in the model, in the DOM
model. Now, it contains the element style
attributes or width and height attributes
as well as match CSS rules based on the selectors
here. Some styles inherited from the container
elements such as font size and font family,
and the--two of the element styles that are
missing on this page. Now this one is editable,
so you can double click to edit the style.
Also, I can traverse using tab key. I can
create new ones using tab keys. I can double
click an empty space to create a new property.
And I can also edit the selector itself so
that I make the rule applicable to a more
or a less elements. Now it's a google.com
page. So it's highly optimized. So all of
the styles are in line, but in case they are
define on a separate CSS file, you'll have
a link here navigating to a particular resource,
to the CSS source itself. Now this next one
is the metrics. And that's the box model for
your element. It shows you the dimensions
of the element as well as padding, margins,
and borders. This thing is editable. Double
click and edit it. We have properties for
DOM elements. Well in fact, DOM elements have
JavaScript wrappers and that's actually how
you talk to the DOM elements from your JavaScript
world. And -these Java Script wrappers are
just JavaScript objects. So you can put arbitrary
properties to those. And that's the place
to inspect them. So we have all the JavaScript
properties in here. We can expand them and
explore more. You see the nice prototype chain
of the select divElement, so that you try
the inheritance here. And the last one is
the Element Listeners. And let me show it
what it does. I'm using--I'm docking it back
and I'm using an inspect tool to inspect the
search field. Now we can see that there are
three types of event listeners registered
to that field. So we've got two blur listeners,
one KeyDown, and a KeyUp. Now for each of
those, I can navigate those sources where
a handler is located, although, google.com
is minified. So you won't see anything good
here but your page is not until--unless it
is deployed. So apart from the source code
navigation, we have event listener properties.
Now the interesting thing about this panel
is that the event handlers are sorted in a
capturing and bubbling order. So they are
displayed exactly as the rendering engine
is going to propagate events through it. That's
what we can see on the screen when I bring
it up. Now let me mention that console is
also a very powerful tool, especially in combination
with the elements panel. So I undocked the
Developer Tools window again and press escape
to bring the console up. Now in the console,
we do support the command line API that is
called the Firebug command line API. And it
includes things like shortcuts for currently
selected elements and that's the "$0" or previously
selected element, it's a "$1." I can dump
properties of the particular of a selected
note, and I can expand it in here. Or I can
navigate my UI to a particular element. I
can monitor events and you can see a nice
code suggestion here "Better registered to
a particular node." So all of these are part
of the Firebug command line API. And you should
make sure that you know how it works because
it's very useful. I think that's all that
I want to tell about the elements panel. And
with that, let me move to the next one, to
the resources panel. I'll be--demo it on the
Gmail sites. So let me navigate to gmail.com
real quick. And let's see what we have here.
Now the resources panel, resources is something
you're spending your time when you're dealing
with network. All the network request against
your web server are going to be registered
here. Let's try to explore what happens when
we are navigating to gmail.com. So the first
entry here is gmail.com and it only has headers
available and we can see that it's a redirect.
We can see a 301 move permanently and--oh,
the response headers. And we've been redirected
to the mail.google.com/mail. Well, it turns
out that the second one is also redirect,
it is PO2. And the reason for that, that I
had missing cookies so I was not log-in and
I'm being redirected to a log-in page. Well,
the next one, the ServiceLogin page. And that's
actually the first page that has been served
with the content. I can see the content preview
in here. I can, of course, see the headers
for this page as well and it's 200. So it
was served okay. Now talking about the previews,
we will support previews for various mime
types such as images, scripts, and styles,
and HTML, and even web fonts. And we are going
to pride it with a nice syntax highlighting
there too. Let me go back to the timeline
view. Now the timeline is something we open
by default and that's the time perspective
from the resource loading. We can see the
latency here. So that's a semi-transferring
part of the bar. That's the time we've been
waiting for response from a server. We can
see a solid part and that's actually time-consumed
for data to be transmitted over the network.
And that's a timeline view on to that. We
also support a size centric view to that.
And those two different sizes are the cell
size of a resource and the size of a resource
transmitted over the network. And they are
different because we are using jZip encoding.
Now it's really simple. It has a several sorting
algorithms in here for size and several sorting
algorithms for resources. We have some basic
filters. So that you could filter resources
from a particular type and that's it. It's
very simple but very useful when you're dealing
with the resources and latency and redirects.
With that, let me move to the scripts. And
in fact, scripts is for debugging. And we
have a dedicated story about Debugging. So
I'm going to skip it right now and I'm doing
the same with the timeline and profiles. We're
going to have a dedicated story for each of
those. And it brings me to a storage. Now
the storage panel is where you manage the
offline content of your application. And the
offline content is for us, HTML5 databases,
we support those. It's a local storage, session
storage, and its cookies. So while we are
in the google.com domain, let me show you
the view of the cookies. You can sort them
here. It's a complete detailed view. It's
not what you're getting while calling the
document cookies. It's a real complete view
on the cookies as they persist in the cookie
manager within Chrome. You can delete them
from here too and you can see the markers
on the HTTP secure cookies too. Now the database
is supported as a SQL command line. It--we
can show you the number of tables that are--that
exist in your database. And that's it. The
local session storages are just the tables
where you can edit things in place. I can
actually show you the HTML5 database sample
on the--one of the notes demo. So the notes
demo is one of the HTML5 database demos, the
very simple ones. I bring it up, and I can
see a table in the database list. I can select
the table and I will see its content. Besides
I can issue a query in here and you can see
a nice suggest. It even suggests, you know,
table names. So I can do search queries in
here. It'll report me if I have any SQL errors
here with a detailed information of those.
So storage is where HTML5 more than stuff
is. And we are going to add even more here.
We are currently working on support for app
cache instrumentation in here. Now going further
to the audits panel and the audits panel is
something that we've recently added. It's
a number of signature checks that you are
running against your page. We are currently
checking your network for the--your page for
being fine with the network utilization and
web page performance. But those--it is base
on the rules engine and those rules are fairly
simple. So we check whether you are not doing
too many requests against the same domain,
that you are not serving images from the domains
with too much cookies, that you are using
caching aggressively, and et cetera. So I
can actually run it against one of the pages.
Let me dock it back and run it against the
Google front page. So its reloading a page
and it is coming up with some hints for me
that, for instance, I should be setting the
cache expiration or cache info for the images,
or I should minimize my cookie sizes because
you've seen there are a lot of cookies on
google.com domain or the wrong use of CSS
rules. So these are new CSS rules, or probably
these ones. They could have been lazy or they'll
audit.. Now we've designed the audits panel
to be extensible and we want third parties
to be able to contribute audit suites into
that. And those audit suites could be random.
It could be mobile readiness, it could be
something related to the network utilization
or something more aggressive that we aren't
currently providing. So we are looking forward
to your feedback on that one and we are open
to adding new stuff into that. Going further,
and that's last panel, but not the least one.
It's a dedicated console panel. That something
our users were asking us to do for a long
time. Before that we are able to open a panel
on the--in the given context using an escape
key. Now we can have a full-blown console
functionality here. You can do Multilang entry
using "Alt+Enter". And console is really a
powerful tool. I find myself spending most
of my time there. Now that's it for the overview.
It's real quick. Again, we'll be touching
scripts and timeline and profiles a bit later.
And once again, this is all available in majority
of WebKit-based browsers should they have
Developer Tools enabled. Now we've talked
about our overview and currently switching
to a completely different thing. We'll be
going through the development stories. And
we'll start with the debugging because I personally
do debugging a lot. And let me start with
a demo. I navigate it to a "goog.ui.HoverCard"
component. That's a UI primitive from the
closure JavaScript library. And what it is
doing? It is providing enrich HTML tool tips
for the elements. So I'm hovering my mouse
over an element and I can see a tool [INDISTINCT]
find it from here, because it is there in
the Gmail. Now, let me try and debug it. For
that, I'm switching to the scripts panel.
And I happen to know that the main functionality
of this thing resides in the HoverCard JS
file. So I typed "HoverCard" and I navigate
to that file. Well, in fact, I even know where
the interesting function is. It's somewhere
around on line 200. And let me set a breakpoint
here, undock it, and let's talk about the
UI that we have. Now that's a debugging environment.
And the center of the screen is your JavaScript
file. And you can choose the JavaScript file
that you are looking at using the file selector.
Now I am currently on a breakpoint and I am
having a stack to the right. And the stack
consists of the frames. Now these stack frames
are the functions that have been called. So
the handle event has called, handle trigger
MouseOver and that one has called trigger
for element. So I can see the complete stack
starting from the event handler. Now all of
these stack frames have friendly names. And
if you look at these trigger for element function
that we are currently in, it is an anonymous
function. It has no name. But we know what
the name is and the reason for that is the
function name inferring that we have embedded
into the weak JavaScript engine. Now for each
of the stack frames, we can see the local
variables. Those are variables available within
the function scope. We can see closure variables
and the global variables. Opening console
will even suggest you the names of this properties
so that it can dump them and that's the state
of this object on this particular call frame.
So you can really get a lot of information
on a suspended state of your JavaScript engine.
Now let me release it from the breakpoint,
given all the view of the rest of the UI.
So we have watch expressions here, you can
enter a watch expression and it'll be re-evaluated
everytime you step through the execution.
We have breakpoints manager and that's about
it. Let me stop on the breakpoint again and
show you something else. And something else
is the on-hover evaluation. That's something
that we have recently added. It can render
primitive values when you're hovering over
them. It will also render complex JavaScript
objects and you'll be able to explore them
on the fly. And for functions, you'll see
there bodies. Like in closure, UI is a name
space and you can see all the classes in this
name space. But it's really a JavaScript,
generic JavaScript functionality. Now that's
pretty standard. Let's talk about something
new. I mentioned that we have been debugging
your application. And you came to a point
in the UI where you know that something is
wrong. And you'd like to fix it. What you
currently do is you'll stop your app, you
go to the sources, you change the sources,
you deploy the app, reload the page, go to
the same place in the UI complete all the
steps that you've done and see whether it
has fixed or not. Now wouldn't it be great
if you could just skip all of that and make
the change in place at this very moment, right
in the JavaScript engine. And in fact, we
now support that. So I'm double clicking on
a line here and it becomes editable. Let me
revert the condition and check if the page
is working. Well, I'm having no HoverCards
anymore. So the page has changed at runtime.
Let me set a breakpoint and see what is wrong.
So I'm hitting this line, I'm trying to step
through it and I'm returning from a function
early. So something is wrong now and the app
is not working. Let me actually fix it back
and do something more complex. I'm adding
a line with a logging here. So I'll be logging
the value of the optional parameter here.
You see the [INDISTINCT] highlighting, so
we did parse the source and we've got a new
content here. Let's see if the app is working
now. Yes, it is back to life. Let's see the
console. We're getting the console entries
for the hover event here. So we are actually
changing the page on the fly. Now, how does
it work? Unlike other JavaScript engines,
V8 is running a highly optimized machine code
even when you're debugging it or profiling
your app. So to change the code on the fly,
we need to actually find the function object
in the VM, patch the machine code for it and
make sure all the other objects are referencing
the new function. If that function is a constructor,
then all newly creation--created objects are
going to use the new code. Now, can you change
the function while you're running it? Let's
try it out. I'm sitting--I'm standing on a
breakpoint in here and I'm doing, yet, another
modification here, some safe one. So what
has happened? I can't continue the execution
of the function that I'm modifying, right?
So what we do is we're kicking it from the
stack and returning back in time to a point
just before calling into that function and
that's the trigger for element. And now if
I step into it, I will have a new body here
with a three equal sign in here. So you can
skip all the hassle and change your application
on the fly, add conditional logging, add whatever
you want into the function bodies and see
it work at runtime. You could also modify
a function to get back to a place before the
function call if you're debugging and seeing
that something went wrong. So we find it pretty
exciting and it's just a preview. We are currently
editing lines and blocks only. But the underlying
V8 capabilities allow us to patch entire sources
to arbitrary changes to a source code on the
fly and we are willing... Oops... Sorry. Are
we okay now? And we are willing to explore
it. Now that's the debugging story and we
have something... Check, check. Is it okay?
Okay. So--and we are--that's the debugging
story and we have added something new to it
that we believe exist only in our app so far.
With that, let me switch to the next story.
And the next story is going to be about performance.
Now, we have our app working properly and
we debugged it well, but it might be slow.
What do we do in that case? Well, what we
do is we start profiling it. Let me open a
canvass DNA model. And go to the profiles
tab and start recording. And while I'm speaking,
it is capturing the stacks from the V8 execution
and sampling them at a rate of 1,000 per second.
When I stop, it'll provide me with the aggregated
information on that profile. Let's explore
it in a bit more detail. I will start with
the top view on the profile. And I can see
here that in this anonymous function, the
animate method has been consuming 96% of time
while I was measuring. Now I can explore it
further and see that it has been rendering
something. And it has been mostly permit lining--drawing
lines and points. Now for each of those, I
can dive in to source and see what's happening
there. Some of those though do not have source
lines associated with them. Let's find out
what are these functions. Well in fact, these
are the functions begin path, move to line
to--and these are native functions defined
on the canvass context. So they are native.
They are implemented by a browser. And you
can't really optimize though--them. However,
you can see what percentage of time or milliseconds
of time we are consuming, and you can minimize
the number of calls into them. Now, these
functions are native. They can even be not
functions but setters, but we are still capturing
the amount of time that has been spent there.
I can switch to the heavy view and heavy view
is just the flat view when the functions are
sorted by their self time, so the more expensive
ones get into the top. And we can see here
that the most expensive ones in this demo
is fill strokes out of strokes, so we can't
really optimize the canvass rendering of the
DNA. But we could cache some strokes--cache
some styles, reiterate over cycles and do
something there. So that's our profiling story.
But that's a JavaScript profiling story. And
the JavaScript is not the only thing that
is happening inside of your browser. There
are other CPU expansive operations consuming
memory and such. And those operations are
calculating CSS styles, primarily dealing
with network, repainting fragments on the
screen, re-flooring your page. All of these
things are taking time and we have a tool
to capture that. And this tool is called Timeline.
Let me show you how it works. I'm docking
Developer Tools back and we'll be exploring
a search result. So I'm looking for purple
flowers. Let me start recording and reload
a page real quick and stop recording. So the
timeline UI, you have an overview on the top
with its three major categories of events
that are happening inside your browser. These
are loading, scripting, and rendering. And
for each of these--could arrays, you have
detailed record list at above. I can zoom
in to a narrow of interest using an overview
panel. I just dragged it and I can see what
has been happening in this timeframe. Now
we can see several send requests. I'm seeing
several event dispatchers. I'm seeing paint
events and even garbage collection there.
Now how do we do that? Well, in fact, we added
a lot of native instrumentation into the WebKit
rendering engine into WebCore. And we are
propagating that information and visualizing
by means of the timeline fountain. Now, if
I expand this evaluate script that has been
happening on google.com, so we were searching
for purple flowers, this script has been downloaded.
It has been executed; the execution is actually
taken about 50 to 70 milliseconds. Now let's
see what was happening inside that script
evaluation. And we can see a number of style
recalculations happening here. Unfortunately,
I'm navigating to a minified source one view
as watch information but we know that they've
been happening here. And we know that we could
optimize it. For instance, we could do some
primitive authorization such as remove an
object from a rendered tree, making some changes
to it, cache them and bring it back, so that
the style was recalculated only once. In this
case, we can see that it's been calculated
several times. And some of them were taking
actual time in CPU. Now we've build this tool
primarily for the performance analysis, however,
we've learned that is a great tool for learning
what your program is about and how it is functioning.
And let me show it to you. I'll be showing
it on the Zippy example. And Zippy is another
closure component that is implementing the
animation of expandable compartments in a
cross-browser manner. Now let's try to find
out how it works using the timeline panel.
For that, I'm starting recording and I'm doing
a single expansion and I'm start-stopping
recording. So let's explore it. There are
random events. And I can see a single large
event click, let me expand it. So I click
a Zippy header. What happened, it called a
function. What that function did, it installed
a timer in the register animation and upon
fire, this timer called cycle animations.
They can see that the cycle animations method,
is its first line removing the timer and is
its last line re-adding the timer. A-ha, so
we are seeing a recursion here based on the
timers. And that essentially what you do when
you want to make a cross-browser animation.
Now, let's see what it ended up with. We're
scrolling down for a second or something and
we can see a latest entry that is clearing
timeout in the unregistered animation. And
that's where the animation stopped. Now let
me remove all the messages in full and putting
up the filter that it removes all the events
less than 15 milliseconds and collapse it.
Now what has happened? From the bird's view,
it's just a single event click. And in fact,
if you were using classical JavaScript debugging
and other techniques, it will tell that the
event click has taken zero milliseconds because
that event click was not possessed anyhow
other than setting up a timer. However, it
has implications that were happening for a
second. Your browser was calculating something.
In fact, it was not only doing JavaScript,
it was also recalculating styles so that the
expandable compartments are animating. Now
how do we do that? Those timers were happening
asynchronously and we are capturing them all
under a single event handler umbrella. So
what we do is for all these synchronous events
in the browser we bind them together. For
instance, the timer fire would be bound under
the install timer so that you knew that the
timer fire has been caused by the timer installed.
And we do the same for resource loading, and
we do the same for exe charts. So we can check
really complex control flows that are happening
asynchronously in your page through that.
And in fact, if I collapse it back you all
see that--let me go back to the google.com
page, get the results. You can see that some
of these were actually happening simultaneously,
which is kind of impossible since the JavaScript
is single-threaded. Oh, the reason for that
is we are tricking not the synchronous execution
time but we are tricking the accusation (ph)
analysis. And if you implement the kind of
a control flow based on timers, you can actually
have several processes happening at the same
time. One process was pulling the surf for
notifications and another was withdrawing
something. So that's our performance and understanding
your code story. It is primarily based on
the profiles and timeline panels. And with
that, we now knew how the page works and we
knew that it was working fast. We even know
that we are beyond JavaScript checking the
native performance of the application. However,
it is not enough. Even if your program is
correct, even if it is fast, if you have a
memory leak, sooner or later it will start
lagging or even make browser do strange things.
So you need to understand how is memory behaving
in your Web application. For that, we have
a memory profiler. I'll be showing--I'll be
demo-ing it based on the Hover card demo.
I'm switching that to the profiles panel.
And I'm clicking this I that is taking a snapshot
of my heap. Before I explain what it means,
let me move my mouse around in here and take
another snapshot. Okay. So the heap, you have
a lot of JavaScript code running inside your
app. And the JavaScript code is creating a
lot of objects and these objects are having
references to each other. So they are retaining
the, all the objects and preventing them from
garbage collected. And what we have here is
object in your heap aggregated by their class.
It allows us to understand that that's class
of a JavaScript object. So we have code objects
from here, some are bit re-objects, closures,
strings, arrays, and we have size in bytes
occupied in the JavaScript virtual machine.
Now we have 95 arrays here, let me expand
it. What it shows when I expand the node is
the classes of the objects that are retaining
arrays. So what this picture is telling me
is that there have been 95 arrays created
in the app and there are objects of these
types downloading the simple pool map logger,
et cetera that have references to these arrays
and prevent these arrays from being collected.
I can expand further and sooner or later,
I'll go to the garbage collection route or
a global property. So if you store a reference
into a window, object it will be there forever
and the property will be preventing the object
from being collected. Now, I've taken two
snapshots; and I've done something in between.
And I make sure you what it tells me. I'm
doing a dip between these two snapshots and
I can see that the snapshot that has been
taken after it has 46 more elements of type
development, has some more strings, et cetera.
Let's try to see who is retaining those. Okay,
so these are objects of type deep (ph) console
and hover card. And these are objects that
have references to these new deeps (ph) preventing
them from being collected. Let's try to find
out in the UI what are these 46 new objects.
Well in fact, that's this event log that is
growing when I'm moving my mouse. So that's
the classical scenario of evaluating your
memory, fighting the memory leaks. You do
something, you take a snapshot, you do something,
you take another snapshot, we compare those.
If you think that no new objects should be
retained, it should have zero difference.
If you want something to be collected, it
should be negative. So that's how our memory
store it. It's also pretty unique to be it
rendering engine. And the JavaScript engine
and the--with that, are we talking about internal
design? No? Okay. We're skipping the internal
design unless you guys want to hear about
the internal design. For what--okay. We can
spend 2 minutes. I'll do it real quick. So
before the internal design, the trusted development,
we are implementing Chromium Chrome, right?
But we are also contributing to V8 and WebKit
to make this function all available. So we
are all WebKit commuters for year, et cetera.
Now these are open source projects and they
are all combined together. The way they are
combined is on a daily basis. Chrome is picking
up the tip of the tree of a WebKit browser.
Then we regularly pick V8 as well, roughly
twice a week. And what it means to you is
that we are having a nice in integration build
pretty much on the weekly basis and they are
available on the dev channel. So if you are
a Web developer and if you want to have latest
and greatest of developer tools, you should
stick with developers' channels, they are
fairly stable at least for doing your Web
development and they have a lot of tools there
that might be missing in this table or beta.
Now, talking about the internal design itself,
the majority of code, source code, is in the
WebKit and basically has a back-end and a
front-end. And the front-end that we've been
seeing here, well, you know what it is implemented
with. What do you think it is implemented
with? This UI, is it a--two options here,
three options. So HTML5, native Python here.
Anything else? So, yeah, right. So it's HTML
JavaScript. And in fact you can even inspected
by its all means. So you just inspect element
on one of the front-end objects and you see
it running. So that's just a web app the front-end
to the right is just web app. It is talking
to a back-end over an IPC and Chrome. So it
is crossing the process boundary, making requests,
getting responses. And this transport isn't
implemented in the Chrome level. Now we will
like it because it allows us doing remote
debugging as well and that's something actually
that we are proud and do working on. With
that, back to Anders.
>> SANDHOLM: Yeah. Thanks very much, Pavel.
So just before we wrap up, I wanted to give
a few pointers. The main place to go if you
want information on the Developer Tools in
Chrome is on the chromium.org site, chromium.org\devtools.
There's a, you know, videos showing how to
get started. There's a full tutorial and so
on. And as Pavel just explained, the bit about
the internal design and how this is all open
source, parts of different open source projects.
We're very much encourage you to contribute
either through, you know, future requests,
the place to go is crbug, or if you want to
find it directly in the WebKit there's a URL
for that as well. Or, you know, if you have
questions about the Inspector or the Development
Tools in Chrome, there's a recent IRC Channel
as well. There'll be people there, as my experience,
pretty much around the clock. There's people
sitting here in California, working on the
inspection and obviously Pavel and his team
in St. Petersburgh is also there. So please,
please go and check it out if we manage to
get you interested in that through this session.
That's it from our side. Thanks very much
for showing interest and I hope you found
some of this exciting. And there's still time
for questions. If any of you have questions,
we're happy to try to answer them. So, thanks.